welcome back to
show what's going on buddy every [__]
week I don't know what happens because I
only use this computer
for this you know I don't touch this
computer I guess I'm not touching it
every [__] week go back to I can't
find the internet I press Safari you
know I'm confused here I press Safari
comes up and then I erase that and I go
to hot mail and I gotta put in 22 codes
for the
FBI you don't have any of your password
saved
anywhere no I don't have no [__]
password my wife's in a [__] softball
game oh my God why is she in charge of
your
passwords I've been doing bang hit since
6:30 this morning that's why there's
your problem got websites and [__] that
I belong to that once I lose I just stop
going
there I'm paying them I forget the code
forget it I'm done all that [__] I you
know there's 22,000 [__] codes you
can't use the same one for everything or
they [__] you
know how many [__] codes you think I
have I know even if I had a bunch of
even if I was a man of many
codes you know how the [__] am I going
to remember all these
Fu but it doesn't really matter how we
going to figure this [__] all right so I
think I might have figured it out click
on second okay I think I might know what
happened Safari no no don't even worry
about Safari right now see at the top
left there's an
apple not for nothing I don't see no
[__]
app next to Safari file edit yeah hit
the CLI that yeah and it takes me down a
[__] Rabbit Hole I'm get on my
skateboard I'm going to get out one of
those [__] fighter things like Hamas
and sail up to [__] Boston tonight
then you really put I'm five edbl in I
don't know what I [__] see no more
hold on let me click this thing again I
gotta figure it out here so I'm gonna go
to Safari and then Here We
goam There we go I'm back like [__]
you know
all right let's get this party started
let's do it let's make sure he gets in
the studio come on open
up got all right there you go I'm coming
in like [__] the big black
Duna hold on now we through another
[__] Opera
Firefox please visit the page on your
laptop desktop or one of these browsers
I don't even know what a [__] browser
is cookies change your
cookies let see what
happen What happens if I go to Firefox
Mission
Dill is protecting Firefox would work
but what happened with chrome
I don't know I don't know where it
[Laughter]
went it just keeps going in this garbage
can but every time I hit
it it Google Chrome Google Chrome with
an arrow that goes into this [__]
[Music]
thing I
keep five
seconds all
right it just made a
noise thank
God okay if you click on the face and
lower left hand corner can you do that
choose a m provider you don't
have why are we opening a
mail at this point I'm over here just
hit
buttons you don't have to hit
mail you don't have to go in the
mail
we're going backwards don't go to
mail yeah when I one click it nothing
happens godam oh you know what hey can
you FaceTime me I'll FaceTime
[Music]
you
minute see what's
happen okay hold on so yeah this is
Safari so we want to get out of here we
don't want to be in here
mother what
this drives me crazy here let's get rid
of this and let's go to this right okay
yeah but you're you're in Safari buddy
so we want to get out of here this this
is this is what is [__] you up all
right where do you want to go all right
so where hit on the lower left there
should be a face there we go like the
last one there we go finder yeah we want
to go to finder there we go perfect and
then you see
applications yes sir okay and okay yeah
you got you got a lot of
chromes so you have three of them so
let's start with the the one on the left
we'll just try that
one okay boom so in that bar and that
like you see where like that link is
written paste do you still have that
link
saved bam and hit
enter
there you
go that's it FaceTime FaceTime is the
answer let's do this all
right we did it oh that took
17 it took 17 minutes and 42
seconds God bless him he's a National
Treasure what up